wow buon pomeriggio a tutti le donne i
cavalieri le armi gli amori
è così che più di 400 anni fa un tale
che rispondeva al nome di ludovico
ariosto dava inizio ad un'opera che
tutti nella nostra vita abbiamo in
qualche modo conosciuto l'orlando
furioso è così che da sempre mi piace
immaginare i rapporti tra uomini e donne
uomini coraggiosi uomini disposti a
combattere anche le battaglie più
sanguinose donne sensibili donne dedite
loro affetti donne tutte prese dei loro
amori
sembra però che la società di oggi non
condivida la visione dell'ariosto sempre
più spesso infatti si sente parlare di
due concetti crisi del maschio moderno
ed emancipazione femminile pre crisi del
maschio si intende il venir meno di atti
di galanteria di coraggio da parte degli
uomini
navigando in internet devo dire che non
ho trovato fonti che testimonino
l'attendibilità di questa tendenza ma
devo ammettere anche che mi trovo
d'accordo con la maggior parte delle
lamentele che vengono mosse dalle donne
stesse in quegli spazi online ovviamente
sempre riguardo alla alla crisi del
maschio moderno prima cipazione
femminile invece si intende e questo il
secondo concetto si intende il
miglioramento delle condizioni di vita
delle donne dal punto di vista culturale
professionale e sociale economico
eccetera eccetera
oggi con voi vorrei concentrarmi proprio
su quest'ultimo punto emancipazione
femminile perché se ci pensate bene di
emancipazione femminile si sente parlare
soprattutto in una chiave sociale
ma se si controllano le statistiche si
capisce che c'è ancora molto da fare a
riguardo soprattutto in questo paese
soprattutto in italia è anche per questo
che quando parlo di questo tema tendo ad
allontanarmi dalle digressioni di tipo
sociologico
per lasciarmi andare ad una prospettiva
personale più legata alla vita
quotidiana di ognuno di noi
per esempio verso la fine dell'anno
scorso ha pubblicato questo breve libro
dal titolo laura unità di misura della
mia vita in quel libro ha preso
riferimento il mio rapporto di coppia
con una ragazza che è lì in mezzo al
pubblico una bellissima ragazza dal nome
laura per volare di relazioni
sentimentali a 360 gradi in quel libro
ho voluto inserire una serie di valori
irrinunciabili per un rapporto di coppia
di qualità
e allora di questi valori oggi vorrei
portarne qui 5 voglio contarli con voi
il primo la necessità di dedicare mille
attenzioni alla donna che amiamo dalle
tutto di noi stessi in un rapporto di
coppia è praticamente un imperativo
categorico
altrimenti non ne vale la pena davvero
secondo valore ricerca di momenti da
dedicare solo ed esclusivamente alla
coppia oggi viviamo in una società che
ci offre un'infinità di stimoli
diventa quindi sempre più difficile
cercare dei momenti da dedicare solo al
proprio rapporto ma dobbiamo provare a
farlo perché dobbiamo provare a farlo
per costruire un'identità di coppia un
concetto fondamentale identità di coppia
quarto valore il coraggio di lasciare il
passato alle spalle
perché forse ieri l'amore su ha fatto
del male forse ieri la moglie ci ha
fatto soffrire ma oggi il sentimento
universale per eccellenza può davvero
farci stare bene può davvero renderci
felici
quindo valore l'immaginazione di
progetti per il futuro della coppia
non sto parlando di disegnare percorsi
precostituiti che il nostro porto dovrà
per forza seguire assolutamente sto
parlando di giocare a sognare un futuro
possibile un futuro insieme
perché non si sa mai che un giorno qui
sogni si potrebbero realizzare qui sogni
un giorno potrebbero diventare la nostra
realtà la cosa interessante
e qui arriviamo appunto la cosa
interessante è che mentre davo voce a
quei valori
e li metteva nero su bianco quasi
inconsciamente stavo scrivendo stavo
tracciando una sorta di strategia per
dare il mio personale contributo
all'emancipazione femminile nel vino e
questo voglio rivolgermi soprattutto gli
uomini presenti in sala
quanti sono alzate le mani gli uomini
voglio vedere le mani ok allora tutti
voi rispettare ed amare fino in fondo la
donna che vi sta accanto
è il primo passo che potete fare per
dare il vostro personalissimo contributo
all'emancipazione femminile per un
attimo piano perché qualcuno a questo
punto potrebbe dirmi beh io non ho una
compagna a fianco io sono single
come posso dare il mio personale
contributo l'emancipazione femminile
allora vorrei ricordare che orlando lo
stesso orlando che mi ha dato l'assist
per iniziare questo spiccia oggi qui con
voi
oltre ad essere furioso era pure single
e quindi orlando si costituisce
l'esempio perfetto di come nella
conquista di una donna si deve essere
tenaci si deve essere tenaci ma senza
perdere di vista la sensibilità e la pre
muria perché perché nella conquista di
una donna la sostanza del nostro
desiderio è delicata e meravigliosa e
allora vorrei concludere così vorrei
concludere dicendo che l'emancipazione
femminile non è un concetto astratto non
lo deve diventare tanto meno deve
diventare un utopia l'emancipazione
femminile è un processo di emancipazione
femminile un processo che si realizza
giorno dopo giorno da dove si comincia
in questo processo
adesso ve lo dico subito si inizia come
detto in questo speech dal rapporto di
coppia in cui siamo coinvolti si arriva
dove si arriva al modo in cui ci
approcciamo più in generale all'universo
femminile e dell'emancipazione femminile
noi non percepiremo tanto i risultati
nel benessere collettivo
lui dell'emancipazione femminile
percepire i risultati nel nostro
benessere personale
grazie a tutti